When I look at just one picture from Simon
Stålenhag’s Tales from the Loop, I feel
like I’ve watched an entire film.
In a single, haunting image, a novel’s worth
of narrative seems to play out just below
the surface.
If you’ve ever seen this art before, you’ve
probably experienced this too — even if
you didn’t know where it was from.
Tales from the Loop and its sequel Things
from the flood are worldbuilding projects
set in an alternate version of Sweden in the
80s and 90s, in which a gigantic particle
accelerator buried beneath the fields and
suburbs begins to alter reality in unpredictable
ways.
Yet the story is so much more than a summary
can convey.
There’s a reason why Stålenhag’s work
has been adapted into an RPG, a board game,
and even a live action tv show.
It is a haunting, atmospheric project that
swallows you whole — and the more scenes
you observe, the more you can piece together
the engrossing narrative below the surface.
So, for this entry into the archive, I want
to dive deep into the hidden lore of Tales
from the Loop — and investigate why this
project has struck a chord with myself and
so many others.
This video will explore the art Stålenhag
has released online, but you can purchase
the full artbook using the links in the description.
Now, let’s enter the world of Simon Stålenhag,
and discover the mysteries of Tales from the
Loop.
The distorted timeline of Tales from the Loop
begins with the Loop itself — the largest
particle accelerator in the world, built to
be so powerful it can warp space-time.
Constructed in the 1960s, the Loop’s presence
can be felt everywhere in the surrounding
Swedish countryside — not just in daily
vibrations and mysterious anomalies, but also
in literal changes to the landscape.
While the Loop itself is underground, monolithic
structures and heaps of scrap metal connected
to the facility gradually overtake the region.
By the 1980s — the period in which Tale
of the Loop is set — the colossal cooling
towers of the central reactor are almost always
in view, with their green lights casting an
eerie glow into the foggy skies.
These scenes, while beautiful, also evoke
a hard-to-place feeling of anxiety, as the
looming structures increasingly overshadow
the seemingly oblivious townsfolk.
Soon, various advancements begin to seep their
way into everyday life.
Magnetrine vehicles — crafts that can float
thanks to a newly discovered levitating force
— become increasingly commonplace in the
world of the Loop.
In the coming decades, several thousand-ton
freighters take to the skies, appearing in
the far background of various scenes, their
artificial lights like distant stars.
The scale echoes the megalithic 80s spaceships
from films like ‘Close Encounters of the
Third Kind,’ with their vast landscapes
of flickering light.
Yet there’s a sense of quiet, unmistakable
dread mixed in with the nostalgia, as these
ships cast a shadow over scenes of ordinary
lives.
Stålenhag seems to be telling us that reality
around the facility is changing, with the
facility’s imperceptible influence leaking
into all aspects of society.
And Magnetrine vehicles aren’t the most
revolutionary machines.
Breakthroughs in artificial nervous systems
allow for machines that walk with a balance
typically only seen in the natural organisms.
Factories produce multilegged machines for
all purposes — from forestry to mining to
warfare.
The region surrounding the Loop becomes a
hub for unmanned units, with strange machines
roaming the woods and backcountry.
Like the towers and hover-ships, these robots
create a distinct feeling of… wrongness,
for lack a better word.
The land itself feels alien and unwelcoming,
a place where the ordinary doesn’t belong.
While Tales from the Loop takes primary inspiration
from 80s media, aesthetically the project
also echoes the enigmatic 70s sci-fi film
Stalker.
Directed by Andrei Tarkovsky, Stalker tells
the story of three men who venture across
a mysterious restricted site known simply
as the "Zone", an area in which the normal
laws of physics do not apply.
At the epicenter of the Zone there exists
a room which can supposedly grant a person's
innermost desires.
It’s… a whole thing, to put it bluntly.
The film is dense, complex, and endlessly
interpretable — but one could argue that
above all, Stalker is a film about atmosphere.
Much like Tales from the Loop, the natural
green landscapes of the Zone aren’t what
we typically associate with sci fi scenery.
Yet through wide shots and the subtle presence
of industrial debris, the countryside of the
Zone feels menacing and distorted — but
in a way that is difficult to rationalize.
While conceptually Tales from the Loop and
Stalker diverge in various ways, this concept
of familiar landscapes rendered unfamiliar
through quiet abnormalities is something central
to both works.
But all the technology we’ve seen so far
in Tales from the Loop is just the beginning.
As the decade wears on, whispers begin to
circulate that the facility is attempting
to create machines able to feel and reason.
Some of these prototypes even manage to escape,
while others are disposed of unceremoniously.
Androids are machines designed to look particularly
human, and many find themselves rusting in
forgotten corners of the land, just one of
many strange objects the Loop’s operations
leave behind.
And there are rumors of stranger occurrences.
Prehistoric monsters begin to appear in the
woods.
In the wake of cosmic energies, a bridge is
created, allowing creatures from the distant
past to wander into the present.
In one image, a group of theropods wander
across the countryside near an empty road,
while arching structures loom in the background.
The feeling of out-of-placeness that these
paintings evoke is heightened, as their subjects
are out-of-time as well.
These dinosaurs have wonderfully retro design
sensibilities, mirroring what you might see
in the original Jurassic Park films or on
old-school dinosaur posters.
In another scene, a group of Hadrosaurids
roam through the snow near the rusting shells
of abandoned Magnetrine vehicles, confused
by this strange new land.
While an exciting image, there’s also a
sense in pieces like these that the Loop is
changing things forever — that these upsets
to the natural order might be too great to
be made right again.
Notably, children feature prominently in most
Tales from the Loop images, and indeed the
entire volume is positioned as the childhood
memories of the author’s alter ego.
A childhood near the facility means these
children are exposed to many things beyond
their comprehension, which they treat as miraculous.
They don’t understand how irrevocably the
world around them is changing.
How could they?
I think on some level, Tales from the Loop
is a story about the cultural memory of the
80s, in which the sci-fi imagery from that
decade assumes literal, physical form.
In this regard, it shares a lot of DNA with
another 80s sci-fi inspired film, Panos Cosmatos’s
Beyond the Black Rainbow.
Released in 2010 but set in 1983, the film
focuses on a secluded research facility called
the Arboria Institute, which houses all sorts
of surreal and unethical experiments.
Over the course of the film, the protagonist
— a girl with latent psychic abilities imprisoned
within the lower levels — slowly becomes
more and more aware of the horrors that the
facility really contains.
The psychedelic narrative moves at a deliberately
slow, hypnotic pace — with much of the plot
coming purely from visual storytelling.
The retro imagery feels born from the same
primordial soup as Tales from the Loop, with
most scenes awash with diffused neon light.
Yet while Beyond the Black Rainbow is ultimately
a story about the loss of innocence and the
destruction of childhood, in Tales from the
Loop, the children never ‘wake up’ to
the terrors of the facility.
Through the lens of childhood, the miracles
of the Loop are just that — miracles.
It’s only us, the audience, that are aware
of how dysfunctional things really are.
As a result, as unnerving as the artbook can
get, it never veers into a full-on nightmare.
Probably because the real nightmares show
up in Things from the Flood.
Released two years after Tales from the Loop,
Things from the Flood is a follow-up artbook
that takes place in the 1990s after the Loop
is supposedly decommissioned — but the strange
occurrences continue.
In Things from the Flood, children are now
teenagers, anguishing from the disillusionment
that comes with growing up.
If the first volume is like a dream, the second
is like waking up, and finding the world is
much less simple than you realized.
Things from the Flood begins with disaster.
The titular flood comes without warning — a
leak from the innards of the decommissioned
loop that floods basements, buries cars, and
leaves towns surrounding the facility half-drowned.
The immediate effect following the flood is
displacement, with the government moving families
whose homes were destroyed by the liquid into
more urban areas further away from the decommissioned
loop.
Here, Stålenhag brings to life a landscape
of exceeding bleak and impersonal office buildings,
which have a disquieting, liminal quality.
Some of these urban landscapes feature colossal
vertical cities: surreal towers consisting
of numerous conjoined buildings — the product
of a public housing program from decades earlier.
One noteworthy element that lurks at the edges
of these sequences are nameless mascots — whose
overly-cheerful and commercialized nature
contrasts bitterly with the gloomy and dower
landscapes.
Their exaggerated smiles reflect the prevailing
ethos around the Loop that ‘everything is
fine,’ although expressions seem strained
and unsettling in such a grim world.
Decaying mascots that continue to smile despite
the ruin creeping in around them are a motif
present in Stålenhag’s art in general,
and I think strike a chord with a lot of people.
There’s something fundamentally mesmerizing
about these images, which give the impression
of a quiet dystopia.
And it’s not just mascots that help create
this atmosphere.
Painted flowers adorn the sides of bare concrete
blocks — and apparent attempt to make up
for what the material world is lacking.
At night, the city itself seems threatening,
lit by neon advertisements suspended above
the skyline by Magnetrine technology.
Scenes like this show hyper-commercialism
creeping into the world of Things from the
Flood, exerting an influence as subtle and
insidious as the loop itself.
Discarded robots also feature heavily in these
illustrations, rusting away in the back alleys
of the city.
On the margins of urban areas, a new population
emerges.
Androids fleeing from demolition sites settle
in the outskirts of the forests.
These displaced machines are called Vagabonds,
and more advanced that the prototypes of the
previous decade — showing an interest in
colorful clothing and complex patterns.
There’s an unmistakable despair and desperation
to many of these portraits of Vagabonds — a
feeling that these are intelligent beings
pushed to the outskirts of a society that
sees them as nuts and bolts.
Clearly, these are machines capable of the
self-expression and individualism we typically
associate only with ourselves, yet according
to passages from Things from the Flood, most
people think of these machines as a nuisance
— or outright fear them.
In truth, their fears should be directed elsewhere.
A sickness overtakes some of the larger machines
— a kind of infection that causes them to
roam around like queasy animals.
Bizarre, organic-look growths begin to form
on their limbs and joints.
Soon, the government is working around the
clock trying to contain these nightmarish
rouge machines.
The official explanation is that the neural
grease that allows their artificial nervous
systems to function has mutated, resulting
in a grim-looking but ultimately harmless
growths.
But if one reads between the margins, another
story emerges: that something from the flood
has leaked into the groundwater, which reacts
to inorganic material in disturbing ways.
For it’s not just large machines that the
sickness is affecting.
In a striking series of images, we can see
how smaller objects made of plastic and metal
mutate into semi-organic forms.
In some pieces it seems like something is
growing inside the empty husks and spilling
out through the cracks, whereas in others
it seems like the objects themselves are melting
away into a living mass.
There’s a real terror to some of these images
— but also something morbidly engrossing,
like the pictures themselves are drawing you
in closer, asking you to ponder every disquieting
detail.
The objects chosen are instantly familiar
from our commercial reality, and yet they
take on an entirely new meaning when presented
in this context.
It’s fitting that Things from the Flood,
a story about growing up from the childhood
shown in Tales from the Loop, seem to take
inspiration from much darker forms of media.
Aesthetically, this section seems to pay homage
to the bodily terror of another 80s sci-fi
film: David Cronenberg’s Videodrome.
Not a work for the faint of heart, the disturbing
cult classic follows the CEO of a television
station who stumbles upon a broadcast signal
showing various criminal acts, and begins
to lose touch with reality as the world around
him seems to become disfigured.
As is the case in Stålenhag’s work, everyday
objects begin to writhe like living organisms,
with the inorganic and sanitized taking on
the properties of the organic and visceral.
To parse the exact meaning behind Videodrome’s
madness would be… an impossible undertaking
in this time frame, but broadly the film seems
to explore concepts of how violence intertwines
with entertainment and how humans can become
desensitized to visceral horrors.
You can see similar themes of desensitization
at play in Things from the Flood, as the public
fails to question the source of the mutations
or even be appropriately horrified by them.
They’ve seen it all before.
Life near the Loop is full of quiet, everyday
terrors.
But in other images, certain infected machines
seem to be evolving.
In some of Stålenhag’s art from Things
from the Flood, we can see almost entirely
organic beings menacing the countryside.
Even more so than usual, there’s an ambiguity
to many of these sequences.
One thing seems clear, however: these fleshy
tendrils and strange growths are growing bolder…
and more autonomous.
In some compositions, they seem more like
independent lifeforms than parasites tied
to machines.
One of my absolute favorite pieces of art
from the Things from the Flood series shows
a small car menaced by two massive beings.
The piece seems to be related to the machine
illness, with the creatures posing similarly
fleshy tentacles, but Stålenhag doesn’t
reveal the exact story behind these lifeforms,
which is part of what makes the image so engrossing.
As is often the case with Things from the
Flood, the ambiguity makes the worldbuilding
all the more intriguing.
Just how Tales from the Loop represents childhood
with its nostalgic atmosphere and more innocent
viewpoint, Things from the Flood is a distinctly
teenage work — all the way down to uncomfortable
red pimples.
Yet at the same time, the story is more than
just melancholy, showing the bright moments
in growing up as well as the dark ones.
I certainly won’t give away the ending to
Things from the Flood in this video, but suffice
to say the narrative continues to embody the
themes Stålenhag established throughout his
larger body of work.
If you’d like to know more of the specifics
of what that entails — you’ll have to
check out the books for yourself…
Tales from the Loop and Things from the Flood
are both haunting and hopeful.
They tell small, ordinary stories in the margins
of massive, world-shaking events.
With solitary images and minimal text, Simon
Stålenhag conjures a world that feels like
looking into the future and the past at the
same time.
And if you find this world as interesting
as I do, you can purchase both artbooks using
the links below to get the full story.
And Tales from the Loop and Things from the
Flood aren’t the only incredible worldbuilding
projects Stålenhag has created.
The Electric State is a richly detailed and
melancholy exploration of a post-apocalyptic
United States, and The Labyrinth is a darker
and more claustrophobic work of cosmic horror.
I’ve got links to those in the description
as well.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.